[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
et puis merci d'être là pour écouter
vous êtes un peu plus long de l'année
dernière moi aussi
[Musique]
bon je vais pas vous de faire un concert
là cette affaire mais je vais vous faire
une conférence sur l'archéologie et plus
précisément sur des sites les sites qui
ont été récupérés par les pouvoirs
politiques
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi ils le
font écrire comment ça se passe parce
que oui
les voeux tas de pierres c'est très
utile aux hommes politiques alors déjà
est-ce qu'on peut dater ce phénomène est
ce qu'il ya une origine précise à la
récupération un les pouvoirs politiques
de vestiges d'anciens alors en fait le
procédé est tellement universel mandiang
ça paraît assez difficile à déterminer
et pour commencer cette conférence bien
avoir en tête que la plupart des
pouvoirs se sont créés dans une
tradition glorieuse sûr moyen pour eux
de montrer leur légitimité
c'est qu'un une continuité qui vont
assurer l'ordre et qu'il a perduré
jusqu'à maintenant pour restaurer un
ordre ancien parce que c'est bien connu
c'était toujours mieux avant
sauf oui car toutes les règles ou leur
exception sauf pour un empire rares
contres exemples mais très emblématique
l'urss
l'urss est un régime et nos militants
régime qui a basé toute sa propagande
sur la modernisation de la société
commune en la fin de tous les archaïsmes
mise à part cette expérience soviétique
les pouvoirs politiques manipulent les
symboles
oui manipule pardon les symboles
historiques pour revendiquer les
traditions communes et en scène par
exemple chez nous marianne symbole de la
république ni plus ni moins que
l'allégorie romaine de la liberté
reconnaissable à son bonnet phrygien qui
censé être celui que portait des
esclaves affranchis
dans l'antiquité c'est ça mon plasma
mourir sur sa chaîne c'est notre
histoire qui a fait une très belle vidéo
sur marianne et continue à paris
l'assemblée nationale est situé dans un
bâtiment inspiré un temple romain on
célèbre les victoires militaires sous
l'arc de triomphe
en remontant les champs elysées qui est
une référence au paradis des guerriers
antilles qui évoque un passé glorieux et
idéal
bon je vous demande un petit effort là
je demandé d'oublier les symboles et les
allégories qui sont trop commun et qui a
trait tout remplissent leur volent les
symboles sont faits pour être récupéré
et manipuler on va s'intéresser à des
objets qui n'ont pas vocation à
l'incarner des programmes politiques
les sites archéologiques déjà c'est quoi
un site archéologique
c'est une trace c'est une trace plus ou
moins visibles de présence humaine assez
forcément un bâtiment une trace
conserver quand le sol ou dans le
paysage comme ici là vous êtes dans
l'archéologie qui nous livrent des
informations sur la société qui doit
produire un site archéologique
ça va du simple trouve dans le sol avec
un tesson de poterie jusque-là de bison
autour d'un feu de camp
ça peut être aussi un châtiment pierre
ou bien encore une cité de paix de
pierre perdu dans la jungle vous doutez
bien pour un pouvoir politique quand il
s'agit de se faire mousser le genre
c'est newcombe victoire avant ma
préférée quelque chose d'un peu classe
on se tourne alors vers les
civilisations anciennes élan cibles sont
les matic car les ruines sont des
sources très précieuse de
réappropriation précieuse car des ruines
majestueuses évoque facilement la
grandeur passée qui a su résister plus
ou moins bien à l'usure du temps
précieux aussi qu'un cyrine sont muettes
imaginez quelqu'un qui est très habile
en communication il pourra leur faire
dire ce qu'il veut ces ruines ils ont
enrobé d'un disque
car sa cause et puis bah sont attribués
tout le prestige a posteriori bon mais
cette démarche n'a rien d'extraordinaire
les mêmes très banal dans l'histoire
l'archéologie les ruines ont toujours
été le sujet de très nombreux grands
partis autour du mystère de
reconstruction attribué parfois
d'extraterrestres une gestion par les
six l'année dernière et boucan
facilement une contemplation de ce fait
logique mais aussi d'autres types de
fantasme politique cela n'imagine alors
une filiation et initi nationale pour
raciales entre les bâtisseurs antiques
et la société contemporaine
et août a aussi besoin complètement la
réalité donc là je passer à des choses
plus concrètes choisi des exemples pour
vous connaissez forcément les nôtres
les mieux lotis en matière de vieux tas
de pierres ce sont les italiens soient
compliquées sont eux qui ont inventé le
béton ya deux mille ans plus tard le
pays est couvert le bâtiment romain
encore debout mussolini fondateur du
fascisme qui prend le pouvoir par un
coup de force en 1922 base toute sa
propagande sur le rétablissement de la
grandeur de rome ils proclament même le
rétablissement de l' empire romain suite
à sa conquête de l'ethiopie en 1936 aux
besoins des étudiants parce que c'est un
triomphe militaire qu'il veut digne d'un
empereur pas quand on veut marcher dans
les pas des endroits anti-ch'tis plus de
trajan le plus facile c'est de restaurer
l'image de la rome antique du moins
l'image consolis en fait là où planter
des fouilles immense dans son premier
dans la zone des forums impériaux c'est
l'endroit où vous mettez forcément les
pieds quand vous arrivez à rome pour la
première fois il va faire détruire tous
les bâtiments qui encerclent les ruines
et qui j'aime sa mise en scène
il a également à concevoir une avenue
entre sa résidence privée
il faut viser s'appelle la bois des
forums impériaux
marcher aussi forcément si vous allez
encore qu'il installe un décor à la
mesure de son ambition
il fait pas que ça ait l'instar des
statuts il fait édifier de nouveaux
bâtiments qui sont aussi inspirés
d'antiquités donc ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que la dictature
fasciste a totalement façonné la ville
actuelle et notre vision d'antiquités en
cluny certes un vaste site archéologique
mais avant tout un cycle à gorki
fascisme deuxième exemple emblématique
le récent mais moins connus dans le
monde occidental
il s'agit de la récupération politique
des cités antiques du moyen-orient elles
sont leurs une nouvelle fois de deux
pouvoirs autoritaires celui du shah
d'iran mohammed reza et du président
irakien saddam hussein alors vous la
lettre l'iran avec mohamed reza ghulam à
vous à l'être l'irak avec saddam hussein
pays voisins puis vous au centre je sais
vraiment pas quoi faire de lui un cadeau
vous êtes le koweït et vous avez encore
dix ans et après faudra alors le premier
en iran fait restaurer les ruines de
persepolis capitale de l'empiré perse ac
et melide et les célèbres grand pont en
les 2500 ans de l'ancienne perse et
l'iran conscient alors pourquoi nos
coûts a fallu prendre je vous
expliquerai après pourquoi cette
cérémonie elle a été filmée vous envoie
quelques extraits sur youtube
qu'est ce qu'on voit en voie de charge
parce que les enfants les enfants non
pour les quand même un short c'est un
bon c'est pas pareil sinon le stand est
très très très visant donc mohamed reza
se place devant la tombe du fondateur de
l'empiré perse qui est cyrus le grand
vous imaginez c'est un mausolée roussin
un immense bâtiment en pierre il
s'adresse et face à ce mur de pierre
s'adresse à cyrus le grand directement
lui dire aux sur une poule sur une mort
de trop les rois des ménages tient pas
que ça ait aussi des militaires qui sont
déguisés en soldats d'antiquités les
plus fausses dents en plastique à
bouclettes noir qui défilent en tenant
des répliques de navires antiques à
échelle 1 tout ça c'est du plastique
aussi et tout ça défile devant les
dirigeants du monde entier dont le
premier ministre de l'époque chaban
delmas qui est très très très
enthousiaste durant cette cérémonie
bon la question c'est pour pouvoir
célébrer l'antiquité en 1960
11 et en inventant une date anniversaire
alors ça peut paraître son rapport je
sais parce que mohammed reza se fait de
plus en plus critiquée par le parti
islamiste et qu'il veut contrer son
influence alors je vais faire un petit
rappel du contexte sont pas forcément
comprendre ce serait dommage blasé 70
plusieurs pays du moyen-orient sont
dirigés par des dictatures plutôt à
l'occidentale terres qu'ils revendiquent
la modernité ou vos économies prix
unitaire et les élites perçoivent leur
nid comme rétrograde qu'elles s'opposent
aux valeurs traditionnelles et donc aux
valeurs de la religion est l'islam mais
ça c'est une partie de la population
qu'elle dirigeante l'élite
j ai tout le reste les populations
opprimées opprimés par ces dictatures il
trouble dans le parti islamiste
une structure qui leur permet de lutter
contre le pouvoir aux panthères que
d'ailleurs les islamistes iraniens avec
l'aide du soutien populaire ont réussi à
virer réserve
en 1979 on bye bye les plats simples
soit huit ans après sa grande fiesta à
persepolis célébrer l'antiquité pour
mohamed reza c'est un moyen pour lui de
milliers l'influencent de la religion
sur son pays
et oui parce que l'islam n'est que le 7e
siècle après jésus-christ milan après l'
empire casse cou quand par là dans les
ruines de persepolis réserve sous-entend
en réalité nous les rois dire en étions
là avant nous sommes une plus légitime
que vous les religieux pour gouverner de
l'histoire est bien le même procédé est
utilisé par le pays voisin l'irak par
saddam hussein
qui prend le pouvoir en 1979 et qu'il
éclaire la guerre un an après en 80 à
amiens
pourquoi baille housseïni lutte
également il a les mêmes ennemis que
mohammed reza les islamistes iraniens
pour lutter idéologiquement entre eux la
parole un truc qui va déterrer un vieux
sites archéologiques alors en irak
c'est le berceau de la civilisation
urbaine c'est là où sont nées les
premières villes donc des cithares piot
et en a les tops et les tempes et le
show ni dictateur va se concentrer sur
une ville particulièrement approprié
babylone un bon coup david l'a déjà
parce que bwin sont majestueuses et déjà
c'est déjà ça ensuite parce qu'elles
sont antérieurs à l'islam
bingo et enfin petite particularité de
babylone elle a été rasée par les
iraniens
durant l'antiquité dont en restaurant
babylone saddam hussein montre qu'il
restaure la puissance de l'irak et qui
le clan pas les irakiens les iraniens
pardon à qui il a déclaré la guerre
qu'on s'est vraiment un coup de pression
militaire symbolique historique
bon d'un exemple
dernier exemple plus léger moins
guerrier et français celui-là glozel
glozel c'est un site en auvergne figée
elle osait dès lors peut-être que selon
vous est familier tu sais pas il s'agit
d'un célèbre faux sites archéologiques
montée de toutes pièces par un amateur
dans les années 20 la wii faire croire à
l'invention de l'écriture sur le sol
français
dans le triste oit pour rappel
l'écriture c'est 3500 ans avant
jésus-christ en mésopotamie
comment on sait pas ce qu'on a retrouvé
des tablettes d'argile avec des petits
signes les formes
cet amateur avec sa pelle de sueurs
froides en bas il fait la même chose
il fabrique des tablettes d'argile et et
grave des signes géométriques
il les met dans son champ avec de la
poterie se doper historique
cette affaire à la fait long feu
franchement c'est taper tout le xxème
siècle et les plus grands spécialistes
de l'époque donc des années 20 à 30 ans
ont fait l'abbé breuil par exemple pas
de la préhistoire celui qu'a décrit en
premier la sco qui était prof au collège
de france il ya cru à l'époque donc
libre a été voté de tarifs qui sont non
ce que révèle cette histoire c'est pas
un scoop intéressons plus tôt c'est pas
tant qu'un petit malin et trash qui est
allé d'argile et les est planqué dans
son champ pour une france c'est plutôt
que la presse française ressortent à
faire donc 2014 en laissant planer le
doute sur l'authenticité de la
découverte
alors ce magazine je vais vous laisser
deviner
le nom quitterait donc la bataille de
glozel l' affaire dreyfus de
l'archéologie l'écriture une invention
française mais de quel magazine peut-il
bien s'agir
valeurs actuelles
ouais bah l'heure actuelle c'est très le
2 octobre 2014
la bataille de beauzelle d'atika
t'attend alors je vais pas vous raconter
en détail cet article maintenant c'est
plus intéressant de vous expliquer
comment sont traités les données
archéologiques dans ce type d'article
parce qu'on a plein de monde parce que
par luxe allemand sur les trois pages
qui sont dédiés aux sites dans la gas in
est jamais question d'archéologie
archéologie n'est qu'un prétexte pour
discuter des notions d'origine de race
et d'attribution de l'invention de
l'écriture via des procédés
scénaristique digne d'une enquête
judiciaire
alors ce cas là quand ça arrive on tombe
sur ce type d'article
la clé pour savoir si ce qui nous est
racontée est douteuse c'est de regarder
sur quelles publications s'appuie une
journaliste pour façon manqué lors
l'occurrence et publications années
20-30 soit la date de découverte du site
donc ça fait près d'un siècle accueille
j avais quelques progrès qui fuit et
puis rapidement en fin d'article à une
petite citation publication 95 mais
quelques limites bien dommage parce que
95 c'est précisément la date du rendu
final du rapport par ministère de la
culture pour ce site
et les résultats sont sans appel
les objets de glozel dont les fameuses
tablettes d'argile sont des contrefaçons
des archéologues et linguiste sont
formels et signe qui apparaît sur ces
tablettes sont empruntés un alphabet la
fin des phéniciens qui date du ive
millénaire avant jc
mais aucun groupe de signes fait sens en
fait monsieur fradin tel un enfant de 5
ans qui ne sait pas encore bien décrire
a simplement imiter des signes qu'il
voyait qui sont en question de langage
après il ya plein de choses qui font
qu'on sait que c'est un faux site et que
valeurs actuelles ne mentionnez pas
évidemment par exemple on a retrouvé des
petites fibres de tissus teintées aux
colorants artificiels
on a aussi trouvé des racines des
petites racines derby zone qui a été mis
volontairement alors dans la table est
l'heure pour d'autres causes sont
toujours des enfants a cédé pour faire
croire que les tablettes avaient passé
un temps assez long un sol pour que des
végétaux fils infiltré la matière et
donc qu'on puisse croire que s'adapter
de la préhistoire est enfin là retrouvez
aussi dans les poteries qui entourait
les tablettes les traces de colle beau
derby entre les colorants artificiels
l'alcool mois dernier l'alphabet du ive
millénaire avant jésus-christ on est de
toute façon très loin la prise corps
donc c'est quoi en fait ce site passer
un atelier de verviers médiévale très
intéressant super chouette mais ça n'a
rien à voir une invention d'écriture en
fait ce que révèle cette histoire c'est
le rôle on attribue à l'archéologie et
dont se servent les politiques
on apprend en archéologie lorsqu'on est
européen que tout ou presque vient
d'orient l'agriculture les villes la
poterie la métallurgie mem les religions
non de là bas en un mot tout ce qu'il
fait la grandeur on est censé être fier
en la rhétorique nationaliste savoir que
tout ça c'est diffusé depuis un berceau
lointain qui plus est aujourd'hui
habitée par de prétendus adversaire la
civilisation européenne suscite le
discours de valeurs actuelles
avant ça plaît pas trop à certains est
ce que montre aussi cet article et qui
est assez grave à mon sens c'est qu'il
est possible de construire une version
alternative archéologiques elle aussi
qui soutient des idéologies en remettant
en question la science officielle selon
eux c'est ce que font les nationalistes
glozel et ses découvertes
sensationnelles permettrait d'attribuer
l'invention d'écriture à l'europe même
plus que ça à la france et surtout pas
au moyen-orient et dans cette logique on
comprend pourquoi ils ont choisi
l'alphabet phénicien ce sont les
orientaux qui vont piquer aux auvergne
en parle à ce vol
pour reprendre un peu les titres là pour
s'amuser un peu l'écriture une invention
française avec ce titre est anachronique
français qu'il n'ya sas que milan la
france s'était notion assez vague
donc il s'érige comme les histoires du
19e siècle la france ont une nation
éternelle est immuable et à les lire on
a l'impression que les politiques ont
gravé les tablettes en chantant la
marseillaise
l' affaire dreyfus de l'archéologie
infirmation bêtement racoleuse qui suit
parfaitement la ligne éditoriale de
valeurs actuelles
et puis généralement les discours
partisan qui ne voient le passé que
comme un outil politique
vous l'avez compris et sites
archéologiques sont récupérés par le
pouvoir politique dans la mesure où ils
peuvent être érigées au rang de symbole
ils doivent être pour cela visitez mon
très visitée par les dirigeants surtout
en bref investi d'une valeur symbolique
spéciale et si pour cela et bien il faut
la reconstruire les remanier les
tronquer leur donner une signification
totalement anachronique et bien ainsi
soit il
je terminerai en rappelant ceux là
s'intéresser à l'archéologie et à
l'histoire c'est pas simplement une
curiosité des connaissances doit être
avant tout un exercice pratique
pourquoi bientôt on parlait de glozel en
2014 pourquoi en dirigeant rend hommage
à une civilisation ancienne s'intéresser
aux usages de l'archéologie apporte un
éclairage sur les manipulations de
certains quand ils prétendent vire les
vestiges en réponse à la poutre à la
politique contemporaine
il faut lire vulgariser visité par dont
les sites archéologiques pour se
désintoxiquer de pas mal de discours
partisan et ne pas se contenter de
mythes porté par des colporteurs peu
scrupuleux en quête d'identité nationale
pour lancer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]